relations between britain and france are
anything but cordial this morning with a
french ambassador to the uk holding to
the foreign office in a rapidly
escalating role over post-brexit fishing
rights the question is how can the
situation be diffused well i'll be
speaking to environment secretary george
euster's in just a few minutes also
ahead
well known women are joining in this
year's movember campaign for men's
health and i'll be speaking to the chief
executive later in the programme plus
[Music]
and we'll be speaking to the director of
a new film about the incredible rescue
of 12 young boys from an underwater cave
in thailand as well as one of the divers
who helped to save them it's friday the
29th of october
troubled waters the french ambassador to
the uk is summoned to the foreign office
as the dispute over the post-brexit
fission rights escalates
our door remains open if log books are
provided that show those vessels are
fished in our waters they will be
entitled to a license under thee
it doesn't fly with me on the eve of
cop26
the woman who led the paris climate
summers criticizes the chancellor's
decision to cut taxes on short-haul
flights
the way that it lands internationally is
not good
and i do think that the prime minister
is going to have to
have some explaining to
a do to fight climate change president
biden arrives in rome to meet the pope
ahead of a g20 summit and cop 26.
underpaid and overworked a special
report on the migrant staff being
exploited and facing insecurity
sending a friend requests facebook
encourages users to embrace a name
change but is better better well i'll be
asking the european boss after eight
and weather looks like it will be shari
for most of us so do grab it brolly
[Music]
hello good morning the french ambassador
to the uk is due to meet the foreign
secretary later after a british scallop
trawler was detained escalating the row
over post-brexit fishing rights
liz trust has summoned the ambassador to
explain what's been described as
disproportionate and disappointing
threats by france well in a moment we'll
be speaking to the environment secretary
george eustis but first our europe
correspondent adam parsons reports from
calais
the cornelius gertian
brought into harbor and seized by french
police who say it has no licence to
operate in french waters
the owners say they've stuck to all the
rules but their boat is caught in a much
bigger dispute here
france wants more fishing permits the uk
says it has to stick to rules before
granting them and frustration has given
way to brinkmanship the french
ambassador has been summoned by the
foreign secretary but france is
unrepentant
the government here in jersey where the
waters are the most disputed says it's
extremely disappointed by the french
government threats and insists it is
giving licenses to fishermen who are
entitled to them
our door remains open if log books are
provided that show those vessels are
fished in our waters they will be
entitled to a license under the trade
deal we've acted with goodwill we've
provided an amnesty period here in
bologna fishing really is the backbone
of the community and plenty here are
happy to see their government standing
up for them
well
france says that unless there is
progress on a deal
then it will stop british boats from
entering its ports as soon as tuesday
plenty of british produce crosses the
channel stopping that flow will be
damaging to both sides the french are
also threatening more checks on freight
going in and out of the uk that would
mean these queues getting worse
at first this looked like just another
squabble between the uk and the european
union but now it's grown into something
else a full-blown diplomatic battle
between the united kingdom and france
and if the french do go ahead with their
threats to ban british fishing vessels
or to gum up customs checks at ports
like halle
that would be incendiary would have big
repercussions on both sides of the
channel the reality is that this is a
row about a small slice of a small
industry
fishing has long been a faultline in the
big brexit picture
now
it is cracking open adam parsons sky
news
well i'm now joined by the environment
secretary george eustis who joins us in
the studio now thank you very much
indeed for your time here on sky news
this morning i think the big question
that most of us want to know is are we
at war with france
well we're not and uh the reality is
that over the last nine months or so
we've actually licensed close to 1700 eu
vessels nearly 750 of those have been
french vessels and what we're talking
about here is a very small proportion of
vessels that the french put forward to
be licensed but the truth is they just
don't have a track record of uh fishing
in the areas where they needed to be in
order to qualify for one so 98 of the
vessels were given a license much
earlier this year even in
jersey they've now issued over 160
licenses to french vessels but there
will always be a small proportion that
don't qualify and that's what we're
talking about here so what is it that
you're going to do then to ease the
tensions at the moment that we're seeing
well look we think that the um the the
comments that have been made by france
on this are you know completely uh
disproportionate they're unacceptable
the the things that they are suggesting
doing which is basically
uh start to be difficult at the borders
and close ports and so on you know this
is um a clear breach not only of the the
trade and cooperation agreement that
we've got with them you know but also of
eu law the official control regime and
so we don't really think it's justified
at all because this is a very small
number of vessels that just don't
qualify under the terms of the agreement
that was reached and so what we're you
know asking france to do is obviously uh
trying to calm this down and and and
remove these threats that they're not
acceptable so what you've said is that
the threats are not acceptable another
thing you've also said is that what
you're going to do is um
make sure that they're met with a
proportionate
level of um you know consequence
basically if those threats are carried
out can you just explain to us what that
looks like from your point of view well
the first thing is um
as the uk the way that we approach these
things in the way that you you should is
we will be uh talking to the european
commission in fact i spoke to the
commissioner two days ago when these um
these threats were first made because
the european commission has got a a role
and a responsibility to make sure its
member states including france abide by
the law and abide by the terms of the
agreement that was reached we've also
summoned the the french ambassador liz
trust the foreign secretary is going to
raise these issues with her and ask her
to explain and give an account of what
they intend to do we don't know what
they'll do they say they wouldn't
introduce these measures until tuesday
probably at the earliest so we will see
what they do but obviously if they do
bring these into place well two can play
at that game and uh you know we
obviously you know reserve the ability
to be able to respond in a proportionate
way let me just pick you up on that
point um the french ambassador being
summoned um what's happened you summoned
last night what's come of it
um well the the normal uh protocol on
this is um you know i would expect at
some point over the next uh day or so
that the ambassador would would meet the
foreign secretary that is um you know
that is generally what happens it's also
possible that the
prime minister will have an opportunity
to to meet president macron obviously
because they'll both be
gathering getting ready for for cop 26.
um you know we we want to defuse this uh
this issue but the truth is we've not
done anything wrong we've abided by the
terms of the uh trade and corporation
agreement and nearly 1700 eu vessels
have been licensed to fish in our waters
we've granted them very generous access
there's a small percentage just two
percent of the applicants
who don't qualify and that's what we're
talking about here and so the reaction
that france have come up with is really
totally disproportionate now we're just
hearing that the french agricultural
minister has just been speaking on
french tv saying that there's been no
progress at all between the uk and
france why is he saying that clearly
nothing is happening nothing is going
forward
well um what's happening is that we've
applied the terms of the trade
incorporation agreement and so
jersey um decided on monday that they
uh the approach that they would take
they communicated that to france and the
commission on tuesday um that was
announced um uh yesterday in the end um
but there were you know i said around
163 vessels uh that had access to jersey
waters that were entitled to a license
they've granted those licenses some of
them on an interim basis until january
while more evidence is gathered but
there are 55 french vessels that had
applied
for access to jersey waters but couldn't
demonstrate a track record during the
reference period so they just hadn't
been accessing jersey waters it might be
understandable they'd like the option to
at some point in the future but that's
not what was agreed and all parties
understood what was agreed through that
trading cooperation agreement i mean
from what you've said france's
government claims that its country's
fishermen lack half the licenses that
they require to fish in british waters
and they're owned they owed them after
brexit is that true no that's simply not
true um why are they saying that then
well um they've been granted as i said
close to 750 licenses uh what we're
talking about here is
around 55 licenses in the context of
jersey that haven't been issued and
haven't been granted but that's because
they don't qualify so they're not
entitled to those licenses that's why
they've not been granted one but what we
have done it's been very generous so far
jersey uh offered interim licenses to
those vessels while they
gathered the data so
they've been very reasonably pragmatic
they didn't really need to do that there
was no obligation on them but they've
been quite generous in their approach
here in the the uk for access to our
insure waters we've also worked very
closely with the commission um and with
the french to try and help them
understand the data that they need to
offer we've even
used data that we have to try to
understand better individual
applications that have been put forward
so we've been
entirely reasonable throughout all this
um we've issued licenses as soon as
we've been able to and as i said to
around 1 700 eu vessels overall let's
pick up on that word you said that
reasonable i think the french looking at
deals like the orcas agreement may think
that the uk has been unreasonable do you
think that tensions from that is playing
a part here
well look it shouldn't because even even
that agreement that was about
um uh three big allies uh the us the uk
and australia you know working uh
together on a um you know defense and
cooperation project focus specifically
around around the pacific so um you know
again i know the french had some issues
uh with that
um but it's really not sensible to say
that major allies like the the uk and us
and australia shouldn't be able to come
to such agreements how much of this
would you say is political grandstand
because obviously macron has elections
coming up next year
yeah well look um there are elections
coming up in france um i've seen
suggestions that that might be a factor
but you know we have to to deal with
what we're we're faced with here which
is really france threatening some
actions that are completely
disproportionate um uh not acceptable
would be a breach of the agreement that
we have with them and uh um that's why
we're we're going to be raising that
with their ambassador and raising it
with the commission
so one of the things that you've
obviously talked about you talked about
how you want to deal with this and the
measures that you hope to put in place
to deal with it but what if france
doesn't actually take on what you're
saying what then what happens if
relations and tensions completely break
down
well look we'll obviously be um dealing
with the european commission and it's
important to to note that because you
know france is an eu member so the
european commission represent them on
these matters we'll be dealing with the
european commission on this um pointing
out to them and explaining that we've
issued now um 1 700 licenses that's 98
of all the applicants
explaining to them and sharing with them
the data so that they can understand
that that remaining two percent you know
just didn't qualify under the terms of
the agreement i think the commission
will understand that and obviously then
you know it's for the commission to
to try to manage um you know raise
relations with france and explain that
uh to france this doesn't bode very well
does it for johnson and macron when they
meet at cop 26 um in just a few days
time
well look in international relations um
there are countries that we you will
sometimes have differences with on
individual issues but i think the the
whole world uh will want to be coming
together to address the big challenge of
climate change and so there are going to
be ministers there from china from
russia many other countries around the
world who were seeking to to build
agreements with
and i think when it comes to climate
change everybody recognizes that
whatever differences we might have on
other aspects of
international policy or domestic policy
or fishing policy
we all put that to one side in order to
address this really big challenge of
climate change okay let's talk about
insulate britain because the high court
order against them is clearly not
working they're still ignoring the
injunction and they're stopping people
from going about their day-to-day lives
and activities so what is it that you're
going to do to stop them from what
they're doing
well the home secretary
announced a few weeks ago
some some plans to strengthen the law in
this area so that we can strengthen the
penalties and give the police more early
intervention powers in cases like this
but at the moment there is that
injunction in place um if they're in
breach of that uh injunction then
they're in contempt of court and the
police do have the ability therefore to
you know to arrest them and take action
but they're ignoring the injunction it's
not having any effect on them whatsoever
um well and if people ignore an
injunction then they are at that point
in content of court so
the injunction is is there for a purpose
which is to give the police the ability
to uh to make arrests and um and
and then move to you know contempt to
court proceedings for those who are in
breach of the injunction let's talk
about um go back to cop 26 as well boris
johnson has said this week that is touch
and go
if it's successful and do you feel the
same does this week's budget really help
at all well look um
these events because they are big
multilateral events with many countries
it is often difficult to to get progress
we've been working incredibly hard
though
on our agenda which is getting more
countries to commit to net zero by the
middle of the century getting
commitments on decarbonising uh
transport and particularly
electrification of cars and in my case
working quite hard on a package around
forests mobilizing finance and getting
agreement on uh you know reducing and
halting the the net loss of forest
around the world so um i'm i'm
optimistic about these agendas but
always obviously when we're in the final
days and the build-up to it
you do get uh you know
nervous about whether you'll get things
over the line certain agreements over
the line there's more to be done at the
actual summit itself um i'm optimistic
um but it is as the prime minister said
touch and go
george eastern's environment secretary
thank you very much indeed for your time
please
still to come we'll be speaking to the
chair of the health and social care
committee jeremy hunt as a new report
calls on the government to improve care
for dementia patients
the first minister of wales mark
drakeford joins us as he tightens some
covered restrictions
[Music]
and as france threatens further action
against british fishermen in the channel
will be joined by the shadow environment
secretary luke pollard just after eight
o'clock
[Music]
now the woman behind the paris climate
agreement has criticized the
government's decision to cut taxes on
some short-haul flights in this week's
budget
just days before the cop 26 summits the
chancellor rishi sunuk carved air
passenger duty on domestic flights
christina figueres the former head of
the u.n climate change convention has
told sky's science and technology editor
tom clark that the decision was very
disappointing
sadly it is the wrong signal and it's
the wrong time for that signal it's
definitely not the flag that the uk
wants to walk in
with uh to cop 26. so that was honestly
very disappointing the way that it lands
internationally is not good
and i do think that the prime minister
is going to have to
have some explaining to do and
how important is that image
for making a successful cop
i do think that the cop presidency has
done a brilliant job of bringing
countries together and staying neutral
to the first task of
upholding the torch that remains to be
seen
and as leaders arrive in glasgow from
around the world we'll have special
coverage of the cop 26 u.n climate
summit that's from 5 pm on sunday night
here on sky news
and for uninterrupted coverage of the
summit including special guests and
analysis you can watch sky news climate
live on channel 525 from 10 am on monday
and also on the great debate on monday
night we'll be asking if it's already
too late to stop the climate crisis
as world leaders gather in glasgow we'll
discuss what cop26 can really achieve
and the steps that governments
businesses and individuals can take to
prevent runaway global warming
join our virtual audience and have your
say by emailing the great debate at sky
dot uk and of course be tuning at 9 pm
on monday
now also making the news this morning
facebook has changed its corporate name
to meta it's part of a major rebrand the
company said it was broadening its reach
beyond social media into areas like
virtual reality we'll be speaking to
facebook's vice president for northern
europe at half past eight
but this is how the chief executive mark
zuckerberg revealed the changes in a
broadcast last night
building our social media apps will
always be an important focus for us
but right now our brand is so tightly
linked to one product that it can't
possibly represent everything that we're
doing today let alone in the future
over time
i hope that we are seen as a metaverse
company
and i want to anchor our work and our
identity on what we are building towards
the armor are responsible for weapons on
the film set where actor alex baldrin
accidentally shot and killed a
cinematographer has insisted that she
always worked safely
in a statement twenty-four-year-old
hannah guterres reid insisted that she
would never allow anyone to use a live
round she said weapons were locked away
at night and says there's no way guns
were unaccounted for or used by crew
members
president joe biden has arrived in italy
for a meeting of g7 g20 leaders the
chinese president xi jinping along with
russia's president putin are expected to
attend a two-day meeting virtually
now there's concern that low paid and
insecure workers are at greater risk of
exploitation because of the pandemic
a campaign group focused on labor
exploitation claims that a large number
of people have their wages withheld
during the lockdown
our business correspondent helen ann
smith reports
the throng of cities the matrix of
modern life is propped up by people
whose work is insecure
but in the shadows there's exploitation
and it's gotten worse
shortly after dorne ivan commutes to
glassy west london originally from
ecuador he's a cleaner and paid below
the london living wage
since the pandemic when some staff were
let go he claims his workload has
doubled for no extra pay he was harassed
if he took a break and wasn't even
allowed to leave the building while on
shift
[Music]
stories like his are often obscured but
not unusual in fact nearly half of
precarious workers surveyed by their
unions said they'd had pay withheld at
some point in the year to july a quarter
were forced to accept worse terms one in
five were too scared to take time off
sick and there are also more reports of
sexual harassment
early lockdowns and job losses left
workers with few alternatives and
therefore fewer choices recent labor
shortages might imply that there are
more options for workers more bargaining
power but for the most vulnerable that
simply isn't the case the pandemics
offered some employers the excuse to
embed exploitative practices and for
those who simply can't afford to take
even a week unpaid or who don't speak
english the risks are simply too high
this is compounded say experts by
inadequate safety nets very low
statutory sick pay and delays in benefit
payouts when the system allows poor
behavior poor behavior happens there are
good secure jobs at the top and then you
have this other class of workers
essentially who don't have those
protections who are low paid they don't
have protection against unfair dismissal
they don't get redundancy pay
they don't have proper sick pay
as the winter and spiraling cost of
living sets in the fear of fighting back
will entrench
times may be tight for employers but the
unseen and the vulnerable should not
bear the brunt helen and smith sky news
well time for that all-important
question the weather what's it got in
store for us
well early rain will turn increasingly
showery today before mostly clearing to
leave showers in the southwest so you
will definitely need your brolly now
local flooding remains a concern in
southern scotland wales and western
parts of england
it's a mild start for many with bands of
rain around but east anglia and kent are
dry central and western ireland look
fine too if chilly in some spots much of
scotland wells and northwest england
will see prolonged rain through the
morning
still to come on sky news breakfast
we'll talk to the chair of the health
and social care committee jeremy hunt as
a new report calls on the government to
improve care for dementia patients
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back the environment secretary
says france is unjustified in seizing a
british trawler and demanding more
licenses to fish in the channel and the
french ambassador to uk has been
summoned to a meeting at the foreign
office by the foreign secretary
well within the past few minutes george
eustis told us he wanted to defuse the
situation
well we think that the
the comments that have been made by
france on this are you know completely
disproportionate they're unacceptable
that the things that they are suggesting
doing which is basically
uh start to be difficult at the borders
and close ports and so on you know this
is a clear breach not only of the the
trade and cooperation agreement that
we've got with them you know but also of
eu law the official control regime and
so we don't really think it's justified
at all because this is a very small
number of vessels that just don't
qualify under the terms of the agreement
that was reached and so what we're you
know asking france to do is obviously uh
try to calm this down and and and uh
remove these threats that they're not
acceptable
well let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell who joins me
here in the studio rob good morning to
you so what do you make of george
eustin's tone i think he is being
diplomatic i think he is trying to take
the high ground talking about working
with france to try and get these
licenses sorted but i think amongst all
of that you can detect some quite hard
language in there he talked about
france's reaction being disproportionate
about it being unacceptable a breach of
the brexit deal a breach of eu law um as
well and crucially when you asked him
about what retaliation might look like
from the uk what the uk would do if the
french went through with these threats
to gum up ports and to stop um british
boats landing on the french coast he
said well two can play at that game so
that suggests that the uk would consider
doing something similar if the french
did carry through with that now lord
frost the brexit minister convened a
meeting last night where some of those
options of what the uk might do
were discussed i think a lot depends now
on what happens between that meeting
with the french ambassador and the
foreign secretary which is going to take
place
later today i think if nothing
productive comes out of that and the
french do go through with these threats
on tuesday you could see something
coming back
from the uk side i think behind the
scenes though the uk are pretty
confident
about the fact that they believe they
have done everything by the book they
say they've been open and transparent
about the process
and in this case it is the french they
believe that are definitely um in the
wrong but we will have to see how this
plays out it also hasn't gone unnoticed
that the eu commission hasn't stepped in
to back up france and i think what the
thought is on the uk side is that the
french might be some out on a limb here
great point there rob thank you very
much indeed thank you
now more money from the government's new
health and social care levy should be
dedicated to dementia patients that's
according to mps the health and social
committee says that the new tax will not
be enough to improve standards of care
when i'm joined by jeremy hunt who is
the chair of the health and social care
committee thank you very much indeed for
your time here on sky news this morning
now firstly you're calling for a 7
billion pound annual increase in funding
for social care by 2023 to 2024. that's
a long way off what the chancellor's
given isn't it
well good morning vanessa yes we
believe and i think everyone knows the
social care sector is in radical need of
an overhaul we welcome the health and
social care levy as a step in the right
direction
but as we've unpacked how much of that
is going to the nhs and how much is
going to the care sector of the the 12
billion pounds only about 2 billion is
going to the care sector our particular
focus this morning is on the 850 000
families in the uk who are looking after
someone with dementia that's a huge
number of people
and what we're really saying to the
government is you know we welcome the
step that's been made we welcome the cap
on care costs but none of this is going
to make a difference in the next three
years and there are lots of things the
government could do much sooner than
that
that would make a really big difference
were you disappointed by the
chancellor's budget for social care
well i think it is
uh a low amount for the social care
sector in the short term the
uh it's about 2 billion just under 2
billion extra a year
and we say as you said earlier that the
budget for the sector needs to go up by
around seven billion pounds a year by
the end of the parliament that is
because of the good news that we are all
living longer
uh but it means that there are a lot of
very vulnerable people um and people
with dementia is perhaps
the example that
we all under understand the most and and
there really isn't a family that hasn't
got someone who's been affected by
dementia or a friend who's been affected
by dementia
and uh so we just want to
raise the red flag really and say you
know for families that are really
struggling in this situation we need
more support sanji javid has promised a
white paper on social care before the
end of the year what we want is a
long-term plan that looks at the support
we give for families with dementia and
the other thing vanessa is how are we
going to recruit the extra 620 000 staff
the care sector gonna need by the end of
this decade
that's something we really need to give
urgent consideration to
well doesn't some of this lack of
funding come from your own time in
government because once upon a time you
were health secretary
yes um i'm now talking about my success
as successor so it's becoming further
back but you're absolutely right we had
a very difficult period of austerity uh
when i was health secretary i fought
hard for a 10-year plan and long-term
funding settlement for the nhs and the
social care sector i was successful for
the nhs
um i was told the social care sector
would come next and then in fairness to
the government you know we had the fall
of theresa may's government brexit
general elections pandemic so
it has been interrupted i think that
process by events beyond the
government's control but now it's
beginning to happen and we've got this
health and social care levy we've got
this white paper coming up so it's
really an opportunity to address these
long-standing issues and that's what we
really hope sajavi will do
mr hunt i'll just move you away from
social care very briefly because you
visited richard radcliffe who's of
course on hunger strike and you wear
foreign sanctuary when his wife nazanin
was detained how is he doing
well i have to say um he's a very very
brave man
i went and delivered some coffee to him
he's allowed to have black coffee on his
hunger strike but nothing with milk or
sugar
and um
you know he has fought tirelessly for
five and a half
years since naznen's been detained but
the thing that's different about richard
is that he decided right from the outset
to go public
about his campaign even though the
advice that him and the other families
were receiving was not to go public
and what that's meant is the whole world
has come to understand iran's
hostage-taking and the way they are
grabbing innocent people putting them in
prison as a pawn of diplomatic leverage
and whatever the disputes are between
countries we should never make
the lives of innocent families dependent
on solving a diplomatic dispute this is
going right the way back to the 19th
century so i i know he met the foreign
secretary i think yesterday
i don't know how that meeting went but i
know that she's actively engaged and i
think we are all just hoping and praying
that nazine does not have to go back to
prison
jeremy hans chair of the health and
social care committee thank you very
much indeed for your time on sky news
thank you thank you
well let's go back to social care
because joining me now is joanne luxton
who's a care manager at the firm pro
medica24 thank you very much indeed for
your time here on sky news this morning
you've been caring for patients with
dementia for 16 years what do you make
of the chancellor's budget for social
care
any money into the system is good but it
needs to be regulated um
looked at where it goes
um you know we need
help for families with dementia there
isn't much help out there
and it's a very difficult time when you
you're struggling with a loved one who's
got dementia
and you're trying to find help support
and it's very difficult there's nowhere
to go nobody directs you when you've got
that diagnosis
it you sort of you get a diagnosis and
that's it in a lot of cases
so yeah any money to the system is good
and also i also have to say that you
cared for your own grandmother um for
quite a number of time as well you know
how is the situation with dementia care
during your time working in the sector
i don't think it has from what i'm
seeing from the you know we're a living
care company and we provide carers that
go in and live with them families are
really struggling to find that that's an
option um it is a very good option um
you know
it's very difficult to do because when
you say dementia patient
one size doesn't fit all it's very
individual it needs to be personalized
to that individual and the family's
needs
um so it's a very difficult subject to
deal with because no no two people are
the same
so
i haven't seen much change since my name
was diagnosed and we really struggled to
find help
i was just going to ask you about that
joe actually what was it like trying to
get that help and support for your nan
difficult very difficult basically we
got the diagnosis and the only option we
were told about was a care home
and that was it
and then you were just left to deal with
it
just tell us what does oh i'm so sorry
joe i hope to to cut you off though i
mean just picking up on you know the
care that you had for your nan what does
the men should do to a family
you don't become a family anymore you
become carers
it is it is very difficult
you struggle because you remember the
person that was there
but they're no longer like that in a lot
of cases and you struggle to deal with
that you've got guilt because you've you
know a lot of people have to ask for
help so you feel guilt
because you're asking for help when you
should be doing it yourself
it's great it's like a grief as well
because that person's gone
you know every now and again they're
there
but in a lot of cases they completely
change their personality and you'll
struggle to deal with that and it it's
very difficult to deal with as a family
joe we really appreciate your time on
sky news this morning thank you so much
for taking the time to speak to us
thank you good morning
good morning to you too
thank you
let's get all the latest on the sport
now here's jackie
chase the pack achieve your goals and
unlock rewards live life with vitality
and zwift the app that makes indoor
cycling fun this sports bulletin is
brought to you by vitality and zwift
it's no surprise to anyone you love the
club when did that start you in
liverpool when i was in chelsea then i
came here
the atmosphere was unbelievable then i
said like wow
i want to play here one day
and that's why when i was in rome and
there is talk between the clubs and they
were saying i will go there i would love
to play there the the atmosphere is
unbelievable
i want to come back to you to england to
to prove people wrong and i didn't have
my chance there chelsea so i will go
back for sure so i came back i also when
i was young i was playing with liverpool
in playstation so it's like there is
kind of emotional between us or between
me and the club so i just like i'm gonna
go so with that in mind then the fact
that it was a bit of a dream to come
here everything you've achieved how much
longer
do you see yourself in the role of
liverpool you know it's a
you know it's a topic at the moment this
is not dependent of me but if you ask me
i would love to stay until last day if
my football but
i can't say much about that not in my
hand okay can i ask you what it does
depend on then
it depends on what the club want not
depend on me at the moment
i can't see myself ever play against
liverpool that would make me sad
and
it's it's hard it's hard i don't want to
talk to about it but it's it will make
me really sad if i at the moment i don't
see myself playing against liverpool but
let's see what will happen in the future
what's left for you you've now been
playing you're in the premier league
african player of the year you've won
the champions league you've won the
premier league
30 next year
yeah
i think what more can you do
i can do a lot i still that's why i'm
always focusing the game just to show
some people that i can play
and top level for many many years i
think i'm in top shape as well can't
play until 38 39 i'm not worried about
that 39 yeah
until my like my kids say hey come play
with us leave it for that would be nice
do you think can top players go on
longer now whereas before it might have
been 32 do you feel like 30 sort of been
beings beginning of the end
live life with vitality and zwift the
app that makes indoor cycling fun
[Music]
jackie thank you very much indeed now
president biden is in italy to meet g20
leaders as he prepares to head for the
cop 26 summit in glasgow
as he traveled to europe last night mr
biden promised to make the largest
effort to combat climate change in u.s
history but he needs support in congress
to make it happen
well our u.s correspondent martha kelner
has been to west virginia and the former
mining town of beckley
i do not believe that we will ever see
probably green energy take over the
world are you aware of cop26
i know that i'm not aware of that
particular conference do you think we're
in the midst of a climate emergency i
think that it's a
cyclic natural event
caused by
rotations of the sun
rural west virginia is a long way from
washington and even further from glasgow
but these are the people president biden
has to convince at home if he's to
become the global leader on climate
change he's now arrived in europe with
wife jill pledging half a trillion
dollars to transition to clean energy
billion metric tons of emission
reductions
at least 10 times bigger on climate than
any bill that has ever passed before but
biden may yet turn up to cop 26 with
empty promises unable to get his own
party to vote for his plan
a last-ditch attempt to unite democrats
on his wider spending bill was
ultimately unsuccessful
the bigger issue though is uniting a
country on climate change and weaning
america off coal and gas and onto
renewable energy
nowhere is that challenge more
pronounced than west virginia
a state built on black gold now
devastated by its decline these coal
workers and activists discussing how to
rebuild their communities what do people
make of president biden and his climate
agenda his climate plans
west virginia probably is not
the most
enamored with some of his rhetoric
the ideas that they're just going to
shove it down somebody's throat
it's not going to fly here
president biden wants to be the world
leader on tackling climate change in
glasgow there'll be big numbers and
bigger ambitions
but at home diversifying from coal and
gas remains bitterly divisive
even in places devastated by extreme
weather where we're standing now it's
completely underwater these houses and
these churches were all
flooded angie campaigns for clean water
access in west virginia she hopes cop 26
will be a breakthrough it is a marker to
say the united states is ready to make a
commitment on climate a big commitment
i'm hopeful that west virginia and the
rest of the world will take note of that
and follow that president biden knows
the next week could define his
presidency america's climate credibility
is on the line his credibility as a
diplomatic forces too martha calmer sky
news west virginia
still yeah monster news breakfast the
first minister of wales mark drakeford
joins us as he warns that covert
restrictions may have to be reimposed
[Music]
so
[Music]
it was from this chamber the carlos
pujamon declared independence in october
i want to show other people what
happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm sky's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores but
simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system will be able
to case
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier i have no time for
any polymix
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
there'll be a mild start for many with
persistent rain affecting much of
scotland northwest england and wales
during the morning the rest of england
will turn more showery whereas island
and northern ireland will be mostly dry
and sunny it'll be mild overall windy
again for england and wales the
afternoon will see rain and showers
clearing into the northeast but more
showers will follow into the southwest
later the unsettled conditions mean air
pollution levels should remain low with
levels between one and three on the
daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
welcome back to sky news breakfast let
me just bring you some breaking news
that we're getting in on that british
trawler that was seized the prosecutor
says that the troller did not have the
required license to operate in the
french economic zone that's according to
reuters that's the news that we're just
getting coming in now and the captain of
the british trawler will be called to
court at a later date we will of course
keep you posted with all the latest
nowels is set to tighten covert
restrictions after a significant rise in
a number of people being treated in
hospital with the virus
anyone aged over five will have to
self-isolate until they have a negative
pcr test when someone they live with has
symptoms or tests positive for
coronavirus well let's speak now to
first minister of wales mark drakeford
thank you very much indeed for your time
on sky news this morning just firstly
just tell us more about those measures
that you're due to announce later
well we will be saying today that we
have to do more here in wales to bring
those numbers down
we want more people to work from home we
want to make sure that people do the
simple things of math squaring in
crowded public places we'll be changing
some of the arrangements in our schools
to try to stem the flow of young people
falling ill with a virus and we will be
asking people who are household contacts
of someone who has tested positive to
stay at home until they themselves have
taken a pcr test
if it's negative they'll be able to go
back to school and to work if it's
positive then they won't have been out
and about
spreading the virus to other
people what's the age group of people
who are getting ill
well the bulk of people who are falling
ill are still the younger age groups but
unfortunately we are seeing growth in
numbers spreading up the age ranges so
in the last week or two we've seen a
higher number of people over 60 falling
ill with coronavirus still more young
people
but the impact of the numbers we're
currently seeing now being felt higher
up the age range as well
miss drakeford you've had some of the
tightest restrictions across um the uk
when it comes to covert but those
figures are still not looking good is
there something you're doing wrong
something clearly isn't working
well i think there are some explanations
of why we are in the position we're in
today
uh wales have a very successful
vaccination program
and it may be that we are seeing the
waning impact of that initial
vaccination earlier here in wales
because of our initial success
it's also the case that earlier in the
summer for weeks and weeks whales had
the lowest level of coronavirus anywhere
in the uk
and it may be that there's just a
greater reservoir of people here in
wales
waiting to be infected by the delta
variant that that's driving the numbers
that we see today what is certainly true
is that numbers at this level are
causing harm in the community are
driving more people into hospital and we
have to make a concerted effort over the
next three weeks to bring those numbers
down
now the uk government at the moment
isn't going near plan b so what i want
to know is how much communication do you
have with them and why are you taking a
different approach
well we do have opportunities to discuss
this with the uk government i have from
a number of weeks been urging them to
move to plan b
would certainly help us here in wales to
have a single communication
that says across england and wales we
are all taking this virus as seriously
as we need to take it as we go into the
autumn and the winter uh in the end
ministers responsible for england make
the decisions they
make and here in wales we make the
decisions that we think are necessary
for us
it does mean that we will take a more
precautionary approach because we do not
want to see
people who need not fall ill fall ill
and we have to attend to the growing
pressures on our hospital system as well
uh mr drake for there is a bit of
confusion and i think you'd forgive a
lot of people for being a little
confused because wells is following
england's lead on removing all countries
from the red list but at the same time
you want to tighten um controls and
bring in tighter measures so
the two just don't think together do
look i they
why they look to be different to the
truth of the matter is that we wish the
uk government took a more precautionary
approach to international travel
but when they changed the rules in
england in any practical sense it's
impossible for us to do anything
different in wales because almost
anybody
almost everybody from wales who travels
abroad or who returns to this country
from abroad comes in through english
ports and airports and then travels on
to wales so in a practical sense we
can't make anything different happen
there although we wish the uk government
took a different approach
well we can do do when we can do things
differently when we have decisions that
we can make effective in wales then we
take them
mark drakeford first mr of scott of
wales thank you very much indeed for
your time
thank you
[Music]
you